[Music]
cali is going to start us off in
indianapolis hi callie how are you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i'm getting married at the end of
august i'm super excited to marry this
man
and we've talked about our deaths from
premarital counseling
i do have a medical debt for my son it
was about 47
000. he was in the pq for a couple weeks
and
i didn't have insurance unfortunately at
the time i do now
so that's taken care of but i was
curious where i put
my medical debt that's actually now in
collections
because it started around covid time so
i couldn't pay it
where would i put that in the baby steps
once we go through financial peace
whenever we get signed up for that where
would i end up putting
my son's medical debt within our other
debt so what do you make
i make 57. what about him he makes 85.
and when you're getting married
august 29th congratulations thank you
how's your baby doing uh he's doing so
much better he is the light of my life
and a lot of my fiance's life he's a lot
better now
fluke incident he aspirated a peanut
so you just uh um you just outlined a
life that is going
really really well and we get to work on
and all we have to work on is some math
stuff
so really good yeah you're in a good
place very nice
and how much debt do you have not
counting this
i have so we have a car i have a car
that's seven thousand that's our
smallest debt
and then i would pay all together i
think we have about
80 000. counting the 47 or not
not counting the 47. what's the rest of
the 80 student loans
he has student loans yeah he's a gm
after
a hotel and then i have my
car and then i also so during covet i
didn't have insurance and that doesn't
help
so i ended up crashing my car and i'm
paying them
12 000 for that okay so
but the biggest number on this is
student loans
the biggest number is just in the moment
there okay all right
now is the uh if uh are they attempting
to collect are you paying any payments
on the 47
i'm not paying any payments right now
his son was supposed to help me that's
our
his father was supposed to help me
that's actually in our mediation
agreement
that hasn't happened yet um but i was
paying payments and then i stopped and
so
it's gone to collections i called about
it and it's at a collection
a collection agency okay right now but
they're not calling on it no
yeah um here's the thing you probably
can settle this for
say 50 cents on the dollar something
like that if you had the lump
sum and so i would take something like a
number like a twenty thousand dollar
number and plug that into your debt
snowball wherever it really goes
it sounds like it's before the student
loans but after some of the car stuff
and i'd build up twenty thousand dollars
cash and i would call them is this
is this a single bill or a total of 47
on medical
it's a single bill it's at a children's
hospital yeah i would also call the
hospital administrator and see if you
can get an
in-person meeting with covet i doubt you
can but anytime you can meet with
someone in person
you can plead your case better and just
go you know i don't have any money
obviously the reason i didn't have i
didn't have i don't have uh insurance
reason i have an insurance i don't have
any money
so if you guys will settle this we we
appreciate the
uh we appreciate the service you gave us
we're thankful for that and
we don't want to be anything but but
honorable but we just don't have
47 000 if you guys will take 20 000 i'll
get it to you really really fast and
then make it a priority if you can get
a settlement agreement but any
settlements you do you do in
writing and uh and you never give
a collector of any kind electronic
access to your checking account because
they
lie it's a problem yeah
dave what happens if she goes to the
hospital and i love that advice
the hospital has an option there to call
the collection agency i presume and say
hey
we want to pull this back we've talked
to them and we're working this out yeah
they can they
don't usually if you just call them yeah
that's why but an in-person meeting
where you go in not accusing the
hospital of having done something wrong
that's right like why do you people
charge so much you know
none of that and you're the price
problem with you no no you
this is a children's hospital to help
you with your child you're grateful
yeah and uh yeah you start with that
and then you go well you know it's just
a math problem it's not a matter of
intent i don't have the money
and if you guys will settle this we can
get it knocked out pretty fast if we're
going to pay the whole 47 it's going to
take a long time
and you most of the time it's
interesting
even people in the administration in
hospitals
hospitals tend to attract people with
mercy yes
merciful people yes and so not always
but they have a tendency to do that
they move into the medical field for one
reason or another and so
you you oftentimes find someone with
heart
but again you're not going in
belligerent no you're not going in
accusing them of having done something
wrong
if you're gonna do that you need an
attorney yes uh but that's
you know because the hospital somehow
malpractice or something like that but
that's not what we're hearing here
no in fact i was gonna say if you have
the spirit that you have on this call
yeah
this is a woman who sees the end she's
gonna knock it out she's excited about
the days ahead
and you know part of this deal is you
got a deadbeat dude on the other side of
this isn't helping i'd share that story
too and go hey
but i'm not relying on him i'm here to
handle this
you help my baby and i want to do the
right thing i think that conviction
along with the spirit she has is very
attractive it is i mean it's just human
nature and it's proper relationships and
but sometimes what happens is we get
afraid um
or we are ashamed and out of those
emotions
uh we we uh project something else
rather than humility we project anger
uh some of the meanest people in the
world are people that are afraid yes you
know
as an example so uh you that's not her
no and so you know i think you knock out
your car then you knock out the car
debt where you uh hit somebody else
without insurance and then you put 20
000
on the list and then you get to the
student loans and you guys just attack
that as fast as you can
any money you get from the ex uh the dad
of the child this
would be called gravy on the biscuit
because it's unexpected
and and you'll get there as fast as you
can now i think we can go a little step
further
and say uh if you have if you're out
there and you let's just kind of do a
teaching segment if you have
a bunch of debts in collection
that you haven't paid on it's been 10
months
20 months since you paid on this credit
card it's been 10 months
20 months since you paid on this uh old
bad
debt from whatever from a medical bill
or whatever else
you make a different list of those
things
when you're working your debt snowball
if you've got a whole bunch of that this
is one singular debt
and it had an unusual story around it
but you'd make you'd knock out your
existing debt snowball first
the ones you're current on because that
frees up all those payments you don't
have anymore
and then you work through the defaulted
student loan or the defaulted debt
snowball
one debt at a time settle it
close it in writing no electronic access
to your checking account
do the next one do the next one do the
next one but freeing up those doesn't
free up cash flow because you're not
paying payments on